we've doubled the funding for the
National Crime agency she's a Home
Secretary who pledged to stop the boats
determined to succeed where her
predecessors failed on a whole range of
measures we've been working on a plan
that is going to fix this unacceptable
problem that being 45
000 people arriving here illegally last
year over 6 million pounds being spent a
day on Hotel accommodation that is an
unacceptable situation can I just get
clarity on what you mean when you say
you want to stop the boats because my
understanding that doesn't mean getting
the number down to zero anytime in kind
of the short or medium term
I think it will be very obvious uh to
reasonable observers as to whether we've
succeeded in our pledge to stop the
boats we say it's clear and simple will
you set a target for where you want the
numbers to be this time next year I
think it'll be very obvious to the
British people and the public as to
whether we've succeeded the British
public won't accept US every year and
come up with another piece of
legislation but behind closed doors the
politics hang on a second let's have a
bit of Common Sense here and do what we
need to do to safeguard the British
public the common sense group of
right-wing conservatives meet regularly
to talk small boats when the people
voted to Take Back Control they meant
their borders they meant their
sovereignty they've pushed for limits on
the role of European judges concessions
granted by the government today from
Worthing to Wolf and so the British
people want to stop the boats but as the
illegal migration Bill reaches its final
stages in the Commons not all
conservatives are happy I would say
rather it's a slap in the face of those
of us who actually care about the
victims of modern slavery isn't in fact
my right honorable friend in effect
asking this house to give legislative
sanction to at least the possibility
that a minister of the crown will
deliberately disobey the international
law obligations of this country
the eyes to the right 289 but in the end
the bill passed with little trouble
one of the reasons that conservative MPS
feel so passionately is because the
issue of small boats is something that
comes up again and again on the doorstep
particularly in places like this with
hotels housing Asylum Seekers they
become a Flashpoint in the argument
about immigration this is dachshit in
Windsor one of the many places where
hotels have been boarded up to house
migrants like Umar since I'm in the
hotel so it's been months you've been in
there yeah I come here 2015.
a long way from Westminster migration
matters local is the cause intentions
the same people that used to let their
children out at night they don't let
them out anymore because then you have
to give them they're honest you know
because you don't know who's in there
the small boats Bill may be sailing
through Parliament but it's people in
places like this the government need to
win over Ali Fortescue Sky News